hahaha
bon après-midi bon après-midi je fais des erreurs comme la
entrez comme ça ok
dîner dans l'après-midi, voulez-vous m'accueillir
du coup Geraldo si tu venais ici
pour discuter de ma proposition sur le
acheter l'appartement ici et il
envoyer cette proposition, n'est-ce pas?
répondu mais imaginez si je suis vraiment celui
choisi de travailler c'est à peu près tout
ton sexe nous sommes venus ici pour parler
la dame
bref une bonne conversation dans les yeux
qui est la même chose que nous avons tous les deux apportée
voici pour vous une contre-proposition qui
super même pas l'appartement du dessus
juste la conversation que nous avons eue
avoir un bébé sur l'achat du vôtre
appartement à cette pré-vente quitte le
appartement exact je ne vendrai pas si le
générer vous savez déjà jours dona carla est
une proposition du visage
dame homme j'aimerais que tu sois là-bas